for decades your organization stayed in
the shadows hiding the truth and now we
know they're among us heroes and
monsters hey youtubers it's Charlie and
agents of shield finally premiered on
ABC welcome to level 7 where everyone
gets one life model decoy in case you
watch the broadcast live you may have
seen my life model decoy during a
commercial for Pringles my friends did a
Star Wars Pringles commercial and just
asked me to be part of it is really cool
it's super creepy to watch myself on TV
but it's good to know I have a backup in
case anything happens to me yeah let's
do a quick recap of the episode and talk
about what it means for the show I also
have some details in the next couple of
episodes including the first super
villain on the show as well as some
behind-the-scenes details about how Joss
Whedon has been helping them fix a lot
of things boilers for everything in
episode 1 so the setup is this Agent
Coulson assembles this team of five
specialists they're basically like a
janitorial crew for superhero messes and
give it like a superhero cop squad
obviously the first threat that they
deal with on the show is J August
Richards he's basically an extremist
enhanced person it's also part of this
special project centipede that I'll talk
about in a minute the first agent we
meet is actually Brett Dalton he's
basically like the James Bond of the
team he's a real loner and they kind of
set up the fact that he has trouble
working with other people so obviously
part of his arc is gonna be learning to
open up to the other members of the team
he's also kind of like the muscle on the
team but Mina is actually the real
muscle on the team she's like the Jane
if you watch Firefly me not is basically
like the Jane of the team if Jane ever
took a desk job so we head back to
shield headquarters and we see Murray
Hill played by Cobie Smulders she'll
probably only be in some of the episodes
of the season because How I Met Your
Mother is still running and her movie
career is kind of taking off we also see
Shepherd buck proving the rumor that in
the Whedon version nobody dies but you
get killed a lot a lot so we start to
learn more about Chloe Bennett she's
basically gonna be like the tech genius
on the team although she's a little bit
hot for a tech genius she basically has
the intel on J August Richards so Agent
Coulson and the team basically need to
take her in so once they do that they
kind of bring her onto the team and we
basically meet the tech CSI twins
they're basically like the CSI of the
team they do a lot of the investigating
if you remember from Iron Man 3
whenever someone with extremists loses
their they basically go nuclear and
explode just destroying everything
around them a big part of this episode
is learning about the extremist threat
and helping J August Richards deal with
that once we do that we find out what
our team is going to be and they kind of
set up the second episode zero eight
four I'll be talking about that episode
in a future video be sure to subscribe
to get it
I also have some details on the episode
three well we'll meet our first
supervillain let's talk about some of
our favorite moments from the episode
let me know it's yours were personally
I'm a huge fan of all of Whedon shows
obviously Joss Whedon is only partially
involved with the series that's merged
at a neuron and Jed Whedon that are
running the show but they basically ran
a lot of his other shows too so if you
like Joss Whedon shows then you will
like this show personally my favorite
moments are really just where the Whedon
moments start crossing over with the
Marvel moments I feel like a lot of the
humorous moments we're really
traditional Joss Whedon so I'm really
looking forward to some of those in the
future obviously Chloe Bennet and Brett
Dalton's characters are kind of set up
as this ship so I think there's gonna be
a lot of comedy between those two
characters they kind of buried the lead
but my favorite character that I'm
actually really looking forward to is
Ming Na
like I said she's basically the Jane of
the team like the heavy weapons expert
the hardcore badass so you learn a
little bit about her character but you
don't learn exactly why she has a desk
job she basically is this super badass
but you're not really sure what's going
on with her something really really bad
probably happened to her in her past
that we're gonna find out in one of the
future episodes so I'm really looking
forward to that
so the show's got great characters great
writers and it's got a great universe to
operate in this Marvel ABC universe so
I'm really looking forward to the show
I'll be doing videos for it every week
be sure you subscribe to get them right
now I just did a video for episodes two
and three with some details about what
we can look forward to as well as the
first super villain on the show you can
click here to get that and you can click
here to get all my other Marvel videos
thanks so much for watching high five
see you guys tomorrow
you